oser jouer tintin au théâtre vous en
conviendrez c'est un pari plutôt risqué
pourtant le succès l'âge 9 une troupe
interprète actuellement les bijoux de la
castafiore et c'est une réussite
marie-hélène bono bernard fut son
objectif théâtre quand les personnages
de papier s'anime tout le monde les
reconnaître tant ils sont ressemblants
sur scène les bijoux de la castafiore
l'oeuvre est respecté à la bulle près 50
séquences se succèdent comme si le
feuilleter l'album sans doute le plus
théâtral d'hergé unité de lieu et
présence de tous les héros récurrent que
l'on retrouve dans tintin
le metteur en scène a obtenu
l'autorisation de la société moulinsart
les héritiers d'hergé impressionné par
son travail
on a passé au peigne fin quoi chaque
chaque image en les analyser et au début
on voulait rendre compte de chacune des
images ce qu'on a bien entendu pas fait
parce que ça serait très indigeste
l'épisode le mieux réussi de la pièce et
le crif n'a invention de tournesol une
performance technique
il a fallu d'abord redessiné agrandir
chacune des vignettes de la bd
remarquable aussi le travail des acteurs
la fluidité et la dynamique des
mouvements
moi mon travail de comédien c'est de
l'inventer de partir du dessin du dessin
d'hergé du centre de gravité toutes ces
choses là et d'inventer ce cas avant est
ce qu'après en essayant de bulbes et en
essayant de rester un petit peu léger là
dedans et ça marche de la case de la
scène il n'y avait qu'un pas qu'il
fallait oser franchir deux ans de
travail
seize comédiens ce spectacle se veut
avant tout un hommage au personnage
inventé par hergé